is this a true story that you were cast
in Django Unchained and you left because
it was out of control or is that just
that's it is I was
casting it but I couldn't do it why is
that because
I'm Quince listening because I loved him
all right yeah I love him I loved him
and I went in and I read with Jamie Foxx
we did readings and stuff and I was so
pumped to do it right and
what happened was
they had problems on Django they kept
pushing they kept pushing them apart
they kept pushing my part they pushed it
for like months and then I got another
job
and and there as soon as I got that job
we're ready for you Queen is ready like
uh
I said I have to not do it because
before you told me you were ready I
committed to this other job thinking
that this was going to continue
nobody told me that you were close to
heated though did you talk to him about
it he never I don't think he ever spoke
to me again
I bet he forgot about it now maybe I bet
it's okay now he has a he has a pretty
amazing memory
like he knew all my movies but I bet he
I bet he's forgiving and understood and
maybe he didn't call you or talk to you
about it was disappointing
I got the sense that he was upset that I
he felt like I made the wrong choice
then I should have by then it was a film
it was an Australian film that had got
all its funding based on my name right
so I really I sat there and kind of did
The Logical math what I liked to be in
in one of Quentin's movies of course I
would
but this movie if I pull out of it
they're going to lose their financing
and I felt responsible to that I knew me
not being in Django Quinton wasn't going
to lose one cent no financing because I
wasn't in it